in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Henry
and Diane are with is it Diane or Dean
San Diane okay I said it right but I
don't look at the smelling okay cool
welcome where you guys from rich Christ
California cool Valley good to have you
in Nashville and here to do your
debt-free scream yes and how much have
you paid off
um one hundred one thousand excellent
how long did that take you about three
and a half years great and what was your
range of income during those years so we
started at 50 and now we're over 135
woah yeah we average 75 while we're
paying off the debt it's a bit of a jump
though in three years did like one of
you not working now both of you working
or something here I wasn't working okay
and you picked up that that's the big
jump then out of that 50 to 135 is a lot
yeah and hard work promotions yeah
absolutely cool so both of you got
raises and promotions but also Diane
started working okay that's a big deal
Wow big push excellent what kind of debt
was the hundred and one thousand all
student loans Wow a lot of selling me
Wow who's that both okay cool so what
happened tell me your story three and a
half years ago something happened so we
just graduated from college a while back
we had a ton of student loan debt and we
just started a new job we moved we had
no emergency fund and both her cars went
out in the same week no so wake up Tom
yeah no I remember that moment cuz the
last time we felt poor helpless you know
we had no we were slaves to the dead we
had no plan we had no emergency fund to
help us and so that was kind of like
when our heart started chained like okay
we need something to to change this yeah
and about a year later they had
Financial Peace University at our church
uh-huh
my mom was like hey you know I heard
this is good for newlyweds you know
financial leads to a lot of arguments so
I'll pay for it if you guys will go
through its we're like alright we'll
give it a shot
and you were radical that's for sure we
were a little surprised you were no debt
of any kind and that's not what we
learned in Business School both of us
together and they were more you use
other people's money
romance everything me too you know so I
first feel like I don't know this guy
might be a little too much but what we
were doing wasn't we're
so pyloric all right let's give it a
shot and never look back
very cool so Diane how do you feel about
your mother-in-law recommending a clash
well if you bet what you got in there is
okay okay very cool fun well that's a
pretty impressive number a hundred and
one thousand and three and a half years
you guys are heroes and way to go you
took control of your life and I loved
what you said Henry where you said
that's the last time we felt hopeless
you you weren't broke I mean and you
weren't rich instantaneously you still
had a lot of fighting to do but when you
realize you can happen to your money
instead of it happening to you something
clicks doesn't it yeah and in the FPU
gave you a step by step and once once we
had that step by step both of us
understood it it was easy to follow it
together yeah that clear path makes a
big difference and when somebody's ready
to follow what it does anyway so very
cool very cool well what do you tell
people when they ask you how did you do
this what are the secrets to getting out
of that well saying saying no to wants
going through the program.we is really
easy to justify things that oh well our
cars broke down so obviously we need a
$25,000 sedan financed because it's you
know reliable and we plan to have a baby
soon so but really figuring out okay
well we have a ton of debt so we can't
really afford that and there's
difference between these and wants
really deep deep diving into what what
was important in our lives
yeah the strange thing is in America we
have almost no needs almost everything
we think we need as they want
really I mean most of us have food
shelter clothing transportation we have
the basics covered but past that nicer
food nicer shelter nicer is a want nicer
nicer we always want nicer there's
nothing wrong with having nicer it's
just a problem when it starts to have
you yeah going through the budget we
realized we were spending hundreds of
dollars eating out pointlessly we didn't
need to do that so one of the things
that helped us going through the
programs we started meal planning at the
beginning of every week we kind of sit
down together do a mini budget meeting
here's all the things we have going on
this week here's the meals we're gonna
do and that helped us keep on track and
really reduce that number of time very
cool
good for you guys excellent job all
right Henry and
I am and the baby is here well how old's
the baby and what's baby's name
she's 13 months oh come here rose Aliya
rose she's precious
very cool all right Henry and Diane and
Halle arose from Los Angeles area
a hundred and one thousand dollars paid
off in three and a half years making 50
now all the way up to 135 a year count
it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one we're dead feet
go you two way to go I love it another
young couple ready to go life is good
this is the way it's supposed to be
excellent job hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show so you have to break
the cycle you have to flip this thing on
its head and make it behave you've got
to get so fired up and wired up that
you're broke friends think you've lost
your mind